il serait injuste de dire que des
manifestations pacifiques au kazakhstan
ont uniquement causé des dommages
économiques il ne s'agit pas de
manifestations pacifiques mais des
meutes de chaos et de pillages
en quelques jours elles sont entraînés
plus de 200 millions de dollars de
dégâts pour le pays principalement ici
dans la ville d'almaty et il s'agit
d'estimations préliminaires car les
dommages réels devraient être beaucoup
plus importants ac match mort
à plusieurs reprises les autorités
kazakhes ont indiqué que ce moment
n'était pas spontanée qu'il s'agissait
de pillage organisé avec des mouvements
de foule visant systématiquement les
centres commerciaux et des entreprises
chantons ce centre commercial les
caméras de vidéosurveillance ont
enregistré des incidents ici comme
ailleurs les pillards ont commencé par
le plus facile les magasins
électroniques les bijoutiers ainsi que
les distributeurs automatiques de
billets ceci par exemple était dans un
magasin de téléphonie
s'il ne reste que quelques appareils kc
les étagères ont été dévalisés en
quelques minutes des gardiens n'ont rien
pu faire alors que la police a répliqué
au tiers des gangs armés pendant ce
temps les pilleurs ont fait main basse
sur la ville
doute tout ceci était planifiée car les
gens qui sont venus et ont failli ci
possédait l'équipement adéquat il faut
avoir le matériel nécessaire pour forcer
les distributeurs automatiques
ils y sont parvenus ils se sont emparés
des liasses de billets bien sûr que ça
fait peur mais citoyens étaient chez eux
après la fête du nouvel an tout le monde
se reposer nous ne savions tous que
c'était lorsque nous nous sommes
réveillés il y avait des citoyens
étrangers là il y avait une sorte
d'agitation là-bas des voix est en
réalité ce bruit a été probablement
causée par des portes qu'on défoncé je
peux dire à retraités je reste chez moi
et j'ai peur de sortir c'est tout c'est
très bien que nous ayons des soldats de
la paix maintenant ces moments ont été
terrifiant pour les civils beaucoup se
sont cachés chez eux lumières éteintes
pour éviter d'attirer l'attention tandis
que les gangs ravagé la ville d'alma si
il ne pouvait rien faire il n'y avait
personne à appeler pour avoir de l'aide
jusqu'à l'arrivée des soldats de
maintien de la paix à l'aéroport
désormais sécurisé d'almaty des
évacuations sont en cours des russes et
des ressortissants d'autres pays sont
évacués vers l'étranger à bord de vols
charters et d'avions cargos militaires
ce qu'ils ont vécu ne peut être décrit
autrement que comme une épreuve
maintenant la situation est revenue plus
ou moins à la normale dieu merci nous
attendions ses vols pour être évacués
west hansell nous avons rencontré cette
foule qui était déjà armé nous logions
dans un hôtel qui donnait sur la place
nous avons vu tout cela brûle et
une centaine de passagers vont être
évacués rien qu'avec ce vol militaire
au total près d'un millier de personnes
ont contacté le consulat russe et ont
demandé à être évacués de la ville
d'almaty
ils embarqueront à bord d'une dizaine de
vols différents
les autorités nous ont indiqué qu'elle
s'attendait à ce que davantage de
personnes contacter le consulat et
demande une évacuation notamment les
ressortissants étrangers